the 49ers apparently will continue to
wait to get their next franchise
quarterback assuming that they have one
now
john lynch general manager of the san
francisco 49ers and one of the new hall
of famers
had this to say on the itest podcast
regarding jimmy garoppolo
if he's injury-free is there any doubt
in your mind that jimmy garoppolo is
your quarterback when you line up in
september
no not at all i mean i i really believe
that he uh
you know i just look at the numbers i
mean he's 25
and 24 9 25 and 9 when he's played um
you know that being available is a big
part of this thing so like i said we we
probably as a stated goal we have to
insulate ourselves better and we got to
have better options if he's not there
um but you know i've watched people go
through this in the career where they
struggle it happened to me early and
then i went eight years without missing
a practice so
i believe that things can happen i i
believe they will for him and
you know i really believe that jimmy is
our guy
sorry but i choose not to believe that
and we've been lied to time and again
strategically by general managers and
coaches
and then when we're lied to we never go
back and say gee look at that there's a
lie there's a lie there's a lie we just
kind of accept it and we move on
and i'm not saying that this is a sin or
anything or it's wrong by john lynch
it's what he has to say he has to say it
because
until they get a better bird in the hand
they're going to hang on to jimmy
garoppolo
and there's a chance that they're not
going to get a better bird in the hand
that they're not going to be able to
trade for a sam darnold that whatever
other plan they come up with
as they're currently in the process of
evaluating their options
may not be enough to say we're moving on
from jimmy garoppolo and going with this
other guy instead but do you really
think anyone
is going to pull out that podcast
appearance and and
bash john lynch over the head with it if
they cut jimmy garoppolo
no so i just choose not to believe it
shireen i mean hell we're in a
at a time now where we can choose to
believe our own facts although i don't
recommend that
i do choose to believe my own my own
things about whether or not
we're being told the truth on strategic
moves made by nfl teams and there's no
reason for john lynch to go on that
podcast or anywhere else and say
you know what we'd really like to move
on from jimmy garoppolo if we can find
someone better
yeah no question about it mike they are
gonna address the quarterback position
whether that's an upgrade on jimmy
garoppolo if they get that opportunity
same desean watson suddenly is on the
market i mean why wouldn't the 49ers
call and get to sean watson
nobody's bringing the podcast back to
say oh my gosh you said jimmy g was your
quarterback but you ended up with
deshaun watson
imagine that no but however they address
it and maybe it is the backup position
ultimately maybe jimmy g does start
another season for the 49ers they've got
to do something
at the back up position if they're
bringing him back whatever that means
and you know cj beathard is an
unrestricted free agent i get the
feeling they don't want him anyway
probably bring back nick mullins who's a
restrictive free agent oh god not
somebody better behind jimmy g yeah
don't br i wouldn't bring back either of
them
sorry sorry hey look congratulations you
made it the nfl you got to play at the
nfl level but
the 49ers are not in good hands with
nick mullins or cj beathard it's time to
move on it's that simple it is a
performance driven business and those
two have not performed nearly well
enough to be the insurance policies
behind
jimmy garoppolo and the other side of
this too is
maybe the 49ers are more than happy to
have jimmy garoppolo come back at a
salary of
15 million not 25. who's going to pay
this guy 25 million if he was cut
right now and available to anyone who
would want to sign him i guarantee you
no one's paying him 25 million this year
he may do a long-term contract that pays
out 25 million in cash as part of a
signing bonus that's different
than getting 25 million in dollars and
cap dollars
this year that isn't happening if he's
available on the open market that's why
i think they're not going to trade him
they're not going to trade him because
they're not going to find somebody to
take on that contract so if no one else
would take on that contract
why in the hell would the 49ers do it
and again they are
stuck with him until they find someone
better and in the event they don't
they gain nothing by going public in
february
saying good god could we find anybody
better than this guy who can't stay
healthy and that's a huge
factor for a quarterback it's one thing
for a safety
who is throwing his body around at
everything that moves to have injury
issues it's another thing for a
quarterback
who's the beneficiary of the most
protection for anyone on the field
except a punter or a kicker after they
kick the ball
short of short of applying the roughing
the kicker rules to quarterbacks and you
can't touch them after they throw the
pass
they are in bubble wrap if you can't
stay healthy as a quarterback
you can't be entrusted with that title a
franchise quarterback and
people like why do you hate jimmy
garoppolo look i i let's be realistic
hey 49ers fans if you want to continue
to not win a super bowl
if you want to continue to say well
who's the backup going to be this week
who's going to be playing the game
instead of jimmy garoppolo
have at it have fun with it enjoy
because that's the future
that you're buying for yourself if you
don't learn from the past
yeah i was going to touch on this mike
john lynch kind of sort of addressed it
but availability is huge
especially for a quarterback and this
guy has missed 23 games of the last
three
seasons and that included the 16 games
that he played
in 2019 so in 2018 and 2020 he couldn't
stay healthy
and you have to have your quarterback on
the field to have a chance i don't care
how well your quarterback plays when
he's
healthy if he's only out there for six
games like he was in 2020 you have no
chance you have to have your starting
quarterback and it's pretty much like
this for any team if you don't have your
starting quarterback you don't have much
of a chance to win now
we've seen nick foles do it in spurts
come on win a super bowl guys like that
we've seen it a little bit but for the
most part
if you don't have your starting
quarterback you don't have a chance and
that's the way it's been for the 49ers
this is a guy who's never made a pro
bowl it's not like they're getting rid
of some guy that's
been in the pro bowl ten times or eight
times or even one time he hasn't been
so they need him to stay on the field
and see if
what they have in him if he truly is
going to be their starter in
in 2021 but i do think if someone
better available comes on the market say
it to sean watson
i do see the 49ers at least making that
phone call and say what would it take to
get this guy
because he would be an upgrade at this
position
and i think the bar is lower than
deshaun watson as to what it would take
to get the 49ers
attention i think that there's a big gap
between watson and garoppolo
and it doesn't take much to be better
than jimmy garoppolo and folks i know
you can be upset with me if you want
look
i'm going to give it to you the way that
i see it if you want raw raw
fake praise for players and teams
there's other networks out there you can
watch we're going to tell you what you
be what we believe here
not what you want to hear and 49ers fans
need to hear
that jimmy garoppolo is not joe montana
he's not steve
young he's not colin kaepernick at his
best he's not jeff garcia
at his best he was right place right
time
stayed healthy for all of 2019. i mean
look back to the 2019 playoffs
he freaked out kyle shanahan by throwing
three balls that should have been picked
off by eric kendrick to the vikings
kendricks picked off one of them after
the third one that was almost picked off
that's when shanahan turned jimmy
garoppolo into bob greasy
and and didn't let him throw the ball
for the entire nfc championship game we
had what
what six passes eight passes something
ridiculous like that so
um hey 49ers fans i'm i'm trying i'm
trying to
to hold your team's feet to the fire to
give you a better overall
organization and it's a shame at a time
when you know the cupboard's otherwise
full
but at the quarterback position it's not
nearly good enough and newsflash
it's not nearly good enough it is more
than good enough for the tampa bay
buccaneers and all 49ers fans i know
last year the
the 49ers considered tom brady he wanted
to come home to northern california and
you said no
you said we'll stick with jimmy oh boy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports